Speaker 1: This almost slipped by me.
But one of our viewers, Allan, wrote to me
about it, and we have to look at it.
Former Trump propagandist Stephen Bannon actually
sat down and did a long form interview with
the failed former president Donald Trump.
And it's fascinating because this is this
is sort of like a vicious circle that we're
going to look at here.
Trump tells many of the lies during this interview
with Steve Bannon that arguably Steve Bannon
created, or at least Bannon created the sort
of approach to politics that leads to Trump
being so comfortable telling these lies.
It's really interesting to see, I guess you
could say, the chef eating his proteges food.
I don't know exactly what metaphor or analogy
makes sense.
So let's look at some of this.
The the formatting.
This is from America's real America's voice
war room with Steve Bannon and their video
player is a mess.
And technologically, it's all a mess.
So I'm going to have to kind of scrub through
the video to moments that my colleague John
flagged for me.
The first thing here is after years of the
whole Crooked Hillary thing, which Trump recently
reassigned to Crooked Joe Biden, Trump now
is saying he never actually thought Crooked
Hillary was that great of a nickname, which
is weird because he used it for half a decade
old problem.
Speaker 3: But I think they like to say that
for other reasons.
You know, like to say he's got a big problem
now because you've given him a nickname.
Well, yesterday was a big day change.
I decided that I've decided that Hillary is
cooked.
We can't do too much better.
You know, I always felt I never felt the Crooked
Hillary was a great name.
I thought it was accurate, but it never flowed
like some of the other half letters in here
from Bill Clinton.
You talk about her.
Speaker 1: So what?
Let's be really frank.
Okay.
Do you think when Bannon says that this this
interview was clearly done the day after the
rally at which Trump announced I'm changing
Crooked Hillary to Crooked Joe Biden?
Do you think Bannon really thinks that it's
a big deal for Trump to change the nicknames,
or is Bannon just playing the sycophant?
Suck up that people around Trump are expected
to play?
I don't know.
I don't know the answer to that.
All right.
Let's now go and bear with me here.
This is just the way we're going to have to
do it next.
Trump says that Rudy Giuliani was the best
mayor of New York ever and that New York has
now collapsed, which is news to everybody
in New York.
Speaker 3: Yeah, went away from his policy
of guns.
You know, what he was doing with the guns,
which basically was started by Rudy.
Look, Rudy was the greatest mayor in the history
of New York and a crime.
I mean, I don't know how you were there.
You were there when when the city started
to collapse.
I saw it.
I saw it collapse.
I saw it come back, Rudy.
And you see the collapse again.
Now it's collapsing again.
And now it's at a level.
And the one thing that's different, we had
a very powerful police force that wasn't being
utilized.
Now, many of those great policemen and women
have left and gone to Texas.
Speaker 1: It's mostly not true.
And NYPD is actually doing fine.
But remember that there's actually some interesting
political history here, which is that Rudy
Giuliani benefited dramatically.
And it's crazy to say it because it was such
a tragic event.
Rudy Giuliani benefited dramatically in the
way that George W Bush did from 911.
Right.
George W Bush saw 80 plus percent approval
in the immediate wake of 911, squandered it
with the Iraq war.
And Rudy Giuliani also became mayor, 911.
And ultimately it became all he talked about
for for about a decade.
But that is certainly a claim that New York
is collapsing, which is hard to find anywhere
as far as data or facts are concerned.
Trump pulling out the idea that America has
gone communist.
And what's really interesting to me about
this is you'll say, well, but David, Trump's
been saying America's communist for, you know,
since Joe Biden the day Joe Biden was inaugurated.
What's interesting is to see Bannon in the
context of having to react to it.
Speaker 3: One of the great things and I think
if we went in 24, I think it's going to be
when we win in 24, the country the country
can't take.
I don't think it can take it.
And I don't think anything.
I don't think we're going to have a country.
You know, this is a business that I don't
think well, even as a politician, they've
weaponize.
You would know this very well.
They've weaponized the Justice Department,
they've weaponized the FBI.
They're doing things that a communist country
would do, a marxist country would do.
It's a very.
Did you ever think this country will get to
that?
I never thought it would be that.
And, you know, with some tough people.
Speaker 1: Now, here is where I know Bannon
is just doing the sycophant suck up stuff.
BANNON Trump may not be smart enough to know
that there's nothing Marxist going on in the
United States.
Bannon is smart enough to know that there's
nothing Marxist happening in the United States.
And so that's where I start to see this and
say, Bannon is absolutely playing a character
here.
He's playing the sycophant suck up character.
Here's Trump with his COVID conspiracies,
for lack of a better term.
Speaker 3: Talking about, yeah, Hunter joking
about Hunter Biden and saying it was Russia
to serve.
I always think, what do you think Putin is
saying when every week they came up with another
thing Russia, Russia, Russia.
They never blamed anything on China because
they were all getting rich from China.
The one way you can tell he's illegitimate
is the lack of respect that they have for
him throughout the world.
Speaker 1: Boy, now that's factually untrue.
If you actually survey people around the world.
Respect for the American presidency and the
country has recovered dramatically since Joe
Biden became president.
They just like they love telling this lie.
He goes.
Speaker 3: You went to school.
We went to Saudi Arabia.
I mean.
Speaker 1: Started the.
Speaker 3: Military's out the thing.
And they go, he's in an SUV with a fist pumping.
The mullahs not respecting the KGB in Moscow
does affect the fist bump.
Who is right here for the historic summit?
No respect for.
I spent three days here.
We had a great we developed a great relationship.
Now, once COVID came, it was like, you know,
that was that was a step too far.
I mean, across the world, millions of lives
and about $60 trillion.
So nobody can ever pay for that, the lives
of $60 trillion.
But they'll pay something.
Don't pay something.
You know, would you demand reparations from
China For me, you can't.
There's no such thing.
A $60 trillion.
You can have 20.
China's okay.
You can, but they cost the world, I figured
because $60 trillion worldwide and, you know,
millions and millions of lives.
What came out of the Wuhan lab, you remember
I was always also this I said, came from the
Wuhan lab.
Speaker 1: It came right out of wall hands.
So TRUMP, you know, kind of reviving that
one.
Then there's a moment which I can't play in
its entirety because I don't want anybody
to, you know, have a medical event from watching
5 minutes of this.
But he he starts lying about immigration for
five straight minutes.
And it's really crazy.
Speaker 3: And take care of American citizens.
People don't realize you also use tariffs
to help secure the border 100%.
Mexico started getting you know, well, they
would have never done it.
I said to the president of Mexico, who I really
like, I have to tell you, he's great.
You know, he wouldn't I don't think to this
day he's even acknowledged.
He said that election was a rigged election.
You said it happened to him ten years before
and he's a socialist.
But you know what?
He's a terrific guy.
But I said, listen, we're building a wall.
And we built I built hundreds of miles of
wall.
That was my first hint that what they wanted
to do was let people pour into our country
from prisons, from mental institutions.
What they have a only the best, only the best,
only the most insane asylum.
You know what I'm saying?
Is that Silence of the Lambs, I'm okay.
Speaker 1: And I don't know why nobody goes.
So it's Silence of the Lambs, Not Silence
of the Lambs.
So continuing to tell those very same lies
about the border, none of that is happening.
And then he moved on to a new favorite target
where he lies about electric vehicles and
the electric vehicle are interesting to me
because it's such a silly scapegoat and it's
so obvious that this is the way that vehicle
technology is going.
It just seems like one of these fights.
That's a very dumb fight to pick.
It'll only work for a little while.
Speaker 3: Everything's the opposite of what
it should be.
We don't want to be energy independent.
We want to spend instead of a dollar 87 a
gallon, we want to spend $9 a gallon.
We want to go to all electric cars that go
for 2 hours, and then you get stuck in the
middle of a road and there's nobody you want.
So forget the car.
How do you get it?
Speaker 1: Doesn't have I mean, quite literally
doesn't happen.
You know, my electric cars range is 330 miles
went New York City to Montreal with, you know,
one stop, which was an optional stop, but
for a diaper change, not for me, but for the
baby.
It why are they attacking electric cars?
Because they've generated an environment in
which people like to hear it and like to see
it without really apparently understanding
the truth of it.
Now, no Trump interview is complete.
Without big dumps.
Speaker 3: The kids have to fight.
I'll give you an example.
You think we have we have enough to get this
done?
I don't know.
That's the one thing.
The Democrats have horrible policy, but they
stick together and they cheat.
The Republicans don't want to cheat.
I said to a man in Pennsylvania, I love Pennsylvania.
I did great.
I was up by almost 900,000 votes or something.
All of a sudden I was even and I said, what
happened?
And you see the chart.
And then there was a dump, big dump.
I mean, it was amazing.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Trump was amazed by the size of the Pennsylvania
dump.
He did attack Alvin Bragg.
I'm going to skip over that, even though I
have it in my notes.
He did attack Ron DeSantis.
And that's another interesting moment here.
And it's curious to see Steve Bannon's reaction
to that.
We're going to take a look at the DeSantis
attacks.
And again, remember, Trump obsessed with the
Sanders despite the fact that he's still not
announced anything.
Speaker 3: Because this is the Donald Trump
that America first fed and now you're under
assault from everywhere.
Total assault, total assault, because we're
winning in the polls.
If I wasn't opposed to 4050 as opposed to
6260, well, DeSantis is failing badly wrong
to sanctimonious.
I mean, you know, it's always bad you endorse
somebody.
He's dead.
He's he's over his dead.
He's going to be looking for a job.
They'll be lucky to get a job.
Comes to me, begs me for a endorsement.
I give it to him.
He ends up winning the election, winning the
nomination, winning the election by numbers
that you wouldn't believe.
I mean, he was so far down, he was gone.
And then they shout to him a couple of years
later, Will you run against the president?
I have no.
Right now, no comment means the answer is
yes.
Speaker 1: Now, that is what this is all about.
That is the the most honest thing Trump has
said in a long time.
This is the narcissism, full fledged.
How dare DeSantis not simply say, I will not
challenge our great orange leader, Donald
Trump?
That's what Trump expects.
That's what Trump considers to be loyalty.
All right.
Last thing.
Continuing to make these silly promises about
how quickly he will solve the situation in
Ukraine.
Speaker 3: He would have never gotten in a
vice president in a million years.
And even the Democrats, they did a poll the
other day, 94% say if Trump was president,
you wouldn't have that horrible catastrophe.
And so many people are being killed, many
more than they report when they blow up a
city, Steve.
And you see all those big buildings and then
they say two people were injured.
It's it's much worse than anybody understands.
I would have that settled in 24 hours.
Yep.
Speaker 1: And of course, and this came up
in my interview with Lex Friedman.
The insistence on Putin wouldn't have invaded
Ukraine had I been president.
It's not really the big gotcha that some of
them believe it to be, because it's completely
plausible that Putin would have seen other
ways to grow his power if Trump were president
rather than Joe Biden.
So a bizarre interview with Stephen Bannon,
but where Trump is right and at the end of
the day, when the rubber meets the road, it's
the numbers
that matter, the polling.